القبايل
والجمهور هو نفسه يعني اتكلم جمهور
الشياطه هو نفسهم اغاني هم نفسهم يسمعون
خالد عبد الرحمن اسمه محمد عبده فلا تقول
لي تيجي تضحك علي وتقول لي والله حنا يعني
جمهور محافظ لا لا
[موسيقى]
سم صالح اليامي هذا الوالد الله يطول عمرك
كان يقول لي كنا رايحين في المطار عمري كم
ست سنوات خمس سنوات وكان عمي الله يطول
عمرك كان حاطني هنا وصغير دخلنا على
الجوازات ويقولون لا لا لا يا ولد اسكت يا
ولد قال حق الجوازات بالله خلها هذا
مستقبل وسبحان الله من ذاك الوقت وابوي
يقول
انت بشكل مجال كذا
اذا بتقيمها فنيا فنيا تجي تاخذ الشيله
الحماسيه
الايقاعاتها خبز وسريعه ما فيها تفاصيل
الاغنيه
ما فيها اركان الاغنيه يعني ممكن نقول
الفرق بين الفرق بين الشيله والاغنيه في
الانتاج
الانتاج الشيله ممكن تسويها بالفين ريال
انتاج الاغنيه اقل شيء 25 الف كذلك الجوده
جوده الشيله مو مثل الاغنيه الاغنيه غالبا
تكون الالات المستخدمه فيها لايف الشيلات
ممكن اللي ميزها في بعض الاحيان البساطه
البساطه التوزيع ما في الات كثيره ما في
زخم
بعض الاحيان عشان كذا ممكن ضربت انا لما
اتكلم في هذا المجال مو معناته انه مجال
الشيلات موفن ترى هذه مصيبه يعني انا سمعت
كذا تصريح يقول لك ما هو فان لا فن يعتبر
فن من الفنون الموجوده بس اللهم انك تسمع
اغنيه صوت هذا صوته
[موسيقى]
يقول لك طار القناه ولا طار الفقر الفن
دخل
مخيف والناس ترى عارفين يعني بعض المواسم
موسم واحد بس شهرين ممكن يوصل الدخل فوق
المليون في الشهر نعم
اعتبر اعتبرها سلعه مثل مثل النفط
في عرض في طلب كثير بس العرض قليل عشان
كذا ايش صار
السعر تبع ايوه فيها امور قبليه وما قبليه
وتعال على فكره
انا محدثك الى الان شغال عليها
لانها فلوس اذا كان انه العمل واحد تاخذ
فيه خمسين ستين الف وما ياخذ منك ربع
ساعات
[موسيقى]
هذا فاتح بيوت شوف الرزق والتوفيق رب
العالمين لكن انا اتكلم مهنيا الفلتر هذا
يعني هو مصيبه اذا ما استخدمته صح فالفكره
انه هذا الفلتر
يعني سواء انت ولا اي واحد من الشباب انا
ممكن اسوي فيكم تجربه افتح لك الميكروفون
اقول لك سجل
على لحم معين وشوف النتيجه اللي بطلعها لك
يعني تقول مثلا اتسلى بال
طراب
هو يسويها لك يرفع فيقدر يلعب في ويفه
الصوت ويقطع فيها ويرفع فوق وينقص تحت
ويسوي له عرضه هنا
انا كل ما اقول المعلومه هذه يجيني يعني
الناس يقولون والله كلامك صحيح يا اخي
جبنا فلان وخليناه يغني في المجلس عندنا
ومره تفشلنا اكثر يعني بنسبه كبيره جدا ان
لم يكونوا اغلبهم
بدايه اكتشاف موهبتهم من هذا الشيء
[موسيقى]
الاغلب يعني
كلهم يطلق عليهم اللي هو منشد ليش اني انا
الاسم هذا تحس انه كذا تحس انه يعني
ممكن نسميه لان اذا قلت منشد
انت على طول لفلك ينزل
لما تقول فنان الليفل هنا فوق اي واحد فتح
كذا فمه قدام ميكروفون وغنى المنشد
الفلاني طيب ايش تعريفك لكلمه منشده غالبا
غالبا اكثر الاسماء اللي موجوده في الوسط
خلاص يقولها واحد والثاني والثالث ورابع
انتشرت مع انه اساسها غلط الانشاد
وذكروها فنانين كبار هو انشاد ديني تراه
صعب جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا جدا واصعب من
الاغاني انا اتمنى اني اكون انشاد صعب
لانك تغني بدون الات موسيقيه فانت لما
يعني تاخذ الاسم هذا
وتسميه به مودين الشيلات مصيبه
انا اقول الصوره النمطيه لما تقول مثلا
فلان في الشيلات
انه صوته
عادي يعني مو بالشخص المحترف
يعني انا اقولها من
الاشياء الصعبه اللي او الاشياء اللي غير
طبيعيه انك تشوف لك محترف في هذا المجال
المحترفين يعرفون وانا اماكنهم ولما تضع
نفسك في مكان
[موسيقى]
لا تلوم الناس على رده فعلهم يعني طبعا
نفسك في المكان اللي يكون يليق فيك شوف
الموهبه الحقيقيه هي اللي تستمر خمسه عشره
عشرين سنه
لنا في محمد عبده
[موسيقى]
انا صرحت كذا مره وانا انا يعني ملتزم
بهذا بهذه النسبه 99% من اللي في الشيلات
اصواتهم عاديه نبره الصوت
حط تحتها عشرين خط نبره الصوت من اكثر
الدارج في الشيلات كلها يعني
[موسيقى]
انت لما لما الواحد يجلس معاك ويغني لك
ابعد لي كل المسميات تعال يا حبيبي اجلس
جنبي ابي اسمع صوتك خليه يغني
انت كذا بتقول والله هذا والله يا اخي في
شيء حلو في طرب
هذا تقدر تصنع منه هو يقدر يصنع من نفسه
فن جميل جدا حتى لو كان انسان اللي تمي بس
يطلع انتاج عمل فني جميل المستمع يسمع
بدون ما ينزعج
تبغى اسمعك يعني
طيب شوف في وحده
كنت اقول
هلو اتسمي
وما يطيق الصبر يوم اللي قلبي ما يطيق
الصبر
وما يطيق الصبر
[موسيقى]
في بعض الشيلات فيها نغم فيها جمل موسيقيه
حلوه
صارت يعني كانها تاخذ من الاغاني شوي يعني
بدات تاخذ من من جو الاغنيه انا لو اقول
لما اسوي اغنيه تاخذ من اجوائها ولكن انت
لما تقول
هل هذه اغنيه يعني تسمع الشيله تقول هل
هذه الاغنيه اقول لك لا ناقصه لا من ناحيه
الصوت ولا من ناحيه حتى طبعا نقطه مهمه
الالحان
شوف مجال الشيلات بشكل عام مافي مهنيه
ثقافه مودين الشيلات
الا ما رحم الله تجدها
موسيقيا ثقافيا حقوقيا قانونيا ما في
احترام للملحن
لو الشعر بيت لما واحد يعني من هالشيلات
تكون له مثلا هذا الحامين
يحس انه عيب
اذا كان هذا في لحن فلان الفلاني تلقاه
ياخذ لحن من فلان الفلاني ولا ياخذ لحن
عراقي ولا ياخذ لحن من المغرب ولا ياخذ ثم
يركب عليه شيله
ولا حتى يكتب انه هذا اللحن كذا كذا الين
ما ينقفط اذا انقفض قال والله هذا لحن
تراث هذا الكلمه اللي يعني
في عصر رقم متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع
في تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول
بكفاءه وذكاء
[موسيقى]
بالمسمى
عشان ما نخلط على الناس ماني مقتنع بمسمى
الشيلات لا اغنيه او ممكن انا اقول لك
بعضهم يعني من مؤدين الشيلات يقول انا ما
انزل فيها موسيقى اكتب على بعض
موسيقى واضحه يعني اقلها الجيتار اللي
موجود تحت يعني هذه مو وراء التريلات
وراها بعد ممكن تستخدمون الطريقه ثانيه
وهذه انا ممكن اتوقع انه ما في الا ممكن
نسبه قليله جدا اللي يسوونها انه هو
يقولها بصوت
يعني يروح يسجل
الكوردات بصوت كذا انا اقول لك هذه ما
فيها موسيقى خلاص قدامك واضح لكن اقول لك
بنسبه انا الاناشيد والشيلات نسبه 99%
كلها موسيقى ليش شفت يعني الحين اكثر
الاناشيد فيه كردات تحت او في بادات اللي
ترى تقدر تنفذها بطريقتين الطريقه الاولى
انك تعزفها في الاله الاورج
فلما عزفتها خلاص هذه موسيقى يعني نضحك
على بعض هذه موسيقى
حتى لو يكون صوت بشري هذه يعني انا اضحك
على واحد من الشباب كان في اغنيه من
الاغاني عندي اسمها عقاوينا وكان فيها عود
المهم يقول لي
هذا عود بشري
[ضحك]
شرفت حبيبي الله يعافيك صفقه
[موسيقى]